our next guest is a former high school
quarterback who didn't cut it at that
position so they moved to Titanic
dealership Cincinnati where he majored
in exploratory studies a third round
pick of the Chiefs Travis Kelce back on
the field he starred in the show
catching Kelsey on the E Network where
he dated women from all over the country
how did that work out for it this season
one hundred three catches for over
thirteen hundred yards ten touchdowns
but most of that's because the
defenseman Tyree killed
despite his success his older brother
Jason can probably still take him in a
fight please welcome Travis Kelce
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh did you expect compliments huh those
weren't compliments well I mean you did
date how many women did you date on that
show oh man um during the show or on the
show well how many did you date after
the show um so far just one wait are you
in love I am in love I have found love
yes love has found me
are you engaged no no oh then you're not
in love out there yeah all right all
right cool okay up what comes for a
Super Bowl ring or engagement ring um
right now I'm looking at that Super Bowl
ring okay so it's a long way away then I
mean the football games gonna be awesome
talk about the Patriots defense then no
I'm actually way more comfortable yeah
no I have no idea what I'm gonna do well
good for you no yeah I'm just living
life you got to enjoy it did you meet
her on the show no I did not I did not
meet her on the show I met her in a
Malibu California how nice I'm not gonna
lie I found her on Instagram found on
Instagram she sent me a DM and it's been
heaven ever since really yeah Instagram
shout-out the Instagram all right good
you can use it for business pleasure all
the above
yeah is the ear ring new I know they're
a little bigger than they were okay
that's why I thought that's the playoff
share yeah exactly yeah imagine if you'd
gone to the Super Bowl yeah they've been
big like big hoops but okay why were you
guys surprised in the first half of what
the Patriots did to the Chiefs um man
I've tried to really put a
[Music]
put it all together and I think it's
just uh it was just it was shocking I
don't know the way they were kind of
playing playing man coverage but you
believe the line of scrimmage and all of
a sudden you go oh we didn't think we'd
see this no no we knew who we were gonna
see we we practiced it all week it was
just um there they were a little bit
more aggressive than we expected and
that's that physical yeah yeah
physically physically aggressive at the
line of scrimmage
grabbing holding and just um getting off
of that man coverage it took us a little
while and at times that we were finally
getting off man coverage Pat was kind of
under duress back there so it's just it
was all in all we just we I hate to say
but we weren't ready for it and you know
in the second half we came out and we
came out firing because we were and then
you wonder it you know as you're
watching like where was this and the for
like how how come you couldn't do that
in the first half but you were so
successful in the second half yeah I
mean it's um it's frustrating I'm seeing
the outcome and that a it took us a
whole half just to catch up and try and
take it into overtime so it was um it's
just uh I mean being that much better
next year being that more aware next
year that's all that can really focus on
right now I'm trying not to hang my hat
on really what happened in the game it
felt like America was rooting for you
guys no I felt it yeah yeah going into
it I mean you can feel that everyone's
kind of sick of the Patriots at this
point do you hate the Patriots I don't
know if it's hate I respect a lot of the
guys over there so I don't I can't call
it hate because there there is a lot of
respect for what they've been able to do
and the careers they've been able to
have I would say that it's more so just
a very very strong competitive dislike
yes okay all right have you ever spoken
to Brady um I shook his hand after the
game they won in New England in New
England yeah during the season their dad
told me unbelievable player so it's
because those things are so awkward it's
so quick when you're saying something to
somebody right yes especially when one
team is lost in the other one yeah it's
kind of different emotions you're mixing
them and
if you had one what would you have
sought out Brady to shake his hand um I
don't know I think I would have been
more celebrating with my teammates he
was okay right yeah because I'm always
curious I don't think you would we just
lost where's Kelsey and I just want to
say I just hope you have a nice winter
there and maybe we'll see you see you in
the play I'm Sarah but you guys had an
unbelievable season if I would have said
at the beginning of the year you got a
new starting quarterback and you're
gonna lose you're starting running back
you're gonna go and play and you're
gonna go into overtime against the
Patriots but you're going to lose the
dramatic fashion
would you have signed up for that no and
that's just because we really believe
that we we had a chance to win at all
and that's uh I mean ever since the
training camp last year when Alex was
with us and I we went out the way we did
last year I mean it was sick to our
stomachs and we knew we had the
Foundation and the players to do it just
fell apart of the goal Lawson lost on a
coin flip man okay what do you think of
overtime I mean it's uh I think I think
it's the rules of the rules obviously so
I'm not gonna sit here and say that we
should have had a chance to do this or
that but being in that situation and and
losing like that it kind of felt a
little like there's an empty feeling in
my stomach just knowing that we didn't
even get a chance to get out there and I
think the only reason why it's really
becoming an issue now is because
everyone really wanted to see you go out
there yeah and try and be a Hall of
Famers but but if if Kansas City won the
coin toss went down and scored nobody
would be complaining about overtime yeah
right I think the Patriots what if you
had the college system if I said to the
players you can vote for the college
overtime or keep what you um I think the
college overtime is extremely exciting I
mean I I've always loved it I mean when
it doesn't matter who's playing they
could be teams that I've never even
heard of that our colleges out there
that I'm locked into the college college
games just because the the OTS are so
like I
what if Jared golf called you and said
hey give me five give me ten minutes on
what I should expect from this defense I
would just say pressure you're gonna
you're gonna get pressure what they do
up front is um they do it very well and
that's they run games they play man
coverage in the back end and then they
throw throw a few different coverages at
you in between to make you kind of
second-guess what they're doing so what
if Brandon cooks calls and says I think
Brandon cooks has an idea of what it's
like having played there yeah okay
I think that's gonna that's gonna help
them out in this game are you rooting
for the QI or are you rooting for the
the Rams because you lost to the
Patriots or would you rather lose to the
team that won the Super Bowl I think we
we lost it both teams but in I just want
to see a good competitive game I mean at
this point I'm just a fan of the game
just trying to see you know good
competition out there I don't really
have a say in which team I want to win
that's just yeah are you gonna watch
yeah watch it I'll check it out Super
Bowl commercials man that's it classic
just like that classic that Manning
Giants commercial last year man you like
that yeah Manning dancing at Eli Manning
dancing dude watch it and beers you're
gonna you know do you do the whole thing
like that food yeah yeah get some wing
you're gonna have to use your brother
coming over now I don't know I think
Jason is gonna be up at Philly cuz your
brother looks like there could be
trouble if he shows up at the pardon
right definitely it is earlier he's
married now so those days are long gone
but he was crazy
oh yeah no he was a nutcase yeah but
there are a lot of there are a lot of
people growing up that said he needed
anger management and my dad just said no
he just needs me because your dad was
the anger management right yep but the
last time you guys fought now did you
talk about the kitchen where oh yeah
don't you guys sit in the kitchen no we
were in the kids that was the last time
like we really uh this and how long were
you
I would say my brother was probably 11th
grade I was I was a freshman in high
school so it was 14 and 16 and how bad
did it get
it really didn't get that bad bad I was
egging them all on the entire time and I
think my dad said he wasn't allowed to
go somewhere so he like threw a temper
tantrum and
sure enough I'm in the kitchen the head
won't you go cry about it or something
[Laughter]
and then he like he died forget what he
had in his hands be like threw it down
and like started running in the kitchen
I'm like ah here we go
and he turned it started off as a
wrestling match and then there were a
few punches thrown and my dad came in
and tried to break it up and sure enough
I'm just like kind of eyes closed he's
got me face looking at the floor and I
just grabbed two legs and I'd pick him
up and I slam him and one leg was my
dad's and sure enough it shook the
entire house there was casserole or
something in the oven and we broke the
oven and the casserole shattered it
wasn't uh it was it was awesome for me
because it was finally like yeah don't
mess with me but honey Apsaras when when
he when my dad my brother hit the ground
my dad like split a disc he's like and
that immediately stopped the fight so
there was no more there wasn't like a
route like retaliation from my brother
too like oh he he just threw me on the
ground I'm really about to pound him out
I was just saying oh wait what's wrong
with that
I said then that stop I was in I was
like dude I won that have you been in a
football fight um I've been in a few
scuffle it's nothing crazy
I haven't I don't I don't think throwing
fists at face mass is the smart you know
why do you guys do that oh no some guys
some guys got some strong fists I guess
yeah but it's stupid it's not it's never
it's never been the smartest thing in my
mind yeah but if I'm smacking you in the
face mask you know the face mask wins
right I would yeah I would assume so I
mean I live in uh the old the old school
slap a guy on the side of there I mean
that good yeah but but I get that yeah
cuz I can rattle your brain a little bit
there right when's the last time your
volved in a fight off the field
man I haven't gotten in too many fights
since that uh since that kitchen scuffle
his word got out yeah we found my dad
hit the ground tell me what you're doing
with the emergent bio solutions yeah so
I'm here partnering with emergent bio
solutions the makers of take home nasal
and alloxan and I'm just using my
platform to spread awareness on the
opioid overdose crisis it's it's touched
home for me because in Ohio they
previously have led the nation in opioid
over overdose deaths yeah our home state
is not good man yeah so it's um I just
wanted to spread the awareness narcan is
something that I think if you know
someone or you're you're on these these
meds just make sure you have it in your
first-aid kit talk to your pharmacist
about this go to WWE where be prepared
calm and just be more aware of
everything that comes with these types
of medications and in the opioids right
and you got to be aware with you
painkillers playing football yes without
a doubt I mean I've always tried to stay
away from them because I mean there's
studies out there that uh that'll blow
your mind man and it's um it's just
something I would rather just stay away
from and kind of push through be aware
be prepared calm to learn more about the
risk prescription opioid painkillers
you're always one of our favorites
Congrats on a wonderful season and good
luck more importantly on love for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]